[Musica]
sin da piccolo i miei genitori mi hanno
insegnato che al mondo esistono due
categorie di persona chi ha bisogno di
aiuto e chi l'aiuto può darlo ma sapete
qual è la caratteristica fondamentale di
questa suddivisione che non è statica
chiunque di noi in qualsiasi momento
della propria vita può essere da una
parte o dall'altra dalla parte di chi ha
bisogno di aiuto o di chi l'aiuto può
darlo credo che sia fondamentale quindi
che ognuno di noi si chiede ogni giorno
da quale parte sono oggi possa aiutare o
ho bisogno di aiuto
personalmente nel corso della mia vita
credo di essere stato molto fortunato
sono cresciuto una buona famiglia ho
sviluppato buone amicizie ho studiato
quello che mi appassionava che poi si è
trasformato nel mio lavoro
spesso quindi sono stato dalla parte di
chi nel proprio piccolo aiuto poteva
darlo ma come si fa ad aiutare davvero
qualcuno come facciamo a sapere di
essere la persona adatta nel momento
adatto per prestare il nostro soccorso a
qualcuno
e con queste domande che inizia la
storia che voglio raccontarvi questa
sera sono cresciuto in una famiglia
profondamente impostata sul servire gli
altri
mio padre medico e mia madre farmacista
e hanno insegnato sin da piccolo a
supportare che aveva bisogno del loro
aiuto dalla mattina alla sera in modo
incondizionato e qui c'è il primo
elemento importante per capire e per
rispondere alla domanda iniziale per
aiutare serve dedizione dedicarsi
completamente ad una causa con passione
e determinazione
e l'unico modo per fornire aiuto a
qualcuno ma sappiamo bene che con le
sole buon intenzioni non si arriva
lontano crescendo mi sono appassionato
sempre di più alla scienza e alla
tecnologia non dimenticherò mai i fiumi
e le dighe miniatura e le trappole
costruite nel giardino di mio nonno
non avete idea di quante volte mio nonno
incappava in quelle trappole e di quante
botte prendevamo io mio fratello per me
quello era un modo di capire come
l'essere umano può influenzare il mondo
come la natura può essere influenzata
creata e distrutta e questa passione che
poi mi porta alla convinzione di
studiare ingegneria inizio quindi a
studiare o sui primi esami e arriva il
momento in cui devo decidere su cosa
improntare la mia tesi di laurea
triennale
in quel momento cercavo una sfida volevo
fare qualcosa di complesso si sa che
quando si è giovani e incoscienti e
quindi decido di riprodurre
meccanicamente uno degli organi più
complessi che la natura umana abbia
sviluppato la mano umana un organo
eccezionale dotato allo stesso tempo di
forza e robustezza leggerezza destrezza
che ci ha permesso di modellare il mondo
in cui viviamo quale era l'unico
problema non ne sapevo assolutamente
nulla zero spaccato ma ero fortemente
motivato quindi iniziò a studiare
comincio a capire come poter riprodurre
una meraviglia del genere e a quel punto
riesco a realizzare la unitesi di laurea
qui si innesta un secondo punto
fondamentale per risponde alla domanda
iniziale per aiutare è fondamentale
avere conoscenza dei problemi più
piccoli a quelli più grandi possiamo
aiutare qualcuno solo se conosciamo il
problema è se abbiamo le competenze per
affrontarli
mi metto quindi l'impegno cominciò a
studiare seriamente cominciato a
profonda ri approfondire i temi ei
problemi vissuti da chi perde l'arto
superiore ma quasi si da subito mi rendo
conto che da solo edificio andare avanti
continuo comunque a studiare sviluppo il
primo meccanismo alla base consente e lo
brevetto e così nasce la prima protesi
bilia unica al mondo completamente
adattiva un dispositivo funzionale e
accessibile che mira a migliorare
concretamente la qualità della vita
degli imputati di arti superiori
come dicevo però mi rendo conto sin da
subito che questo non è un progetto devo
affrontare un individuo solo in questo
momento sono io ad aver bisogno di aiuto
coinvolgo quindi due miei colleghi
matteo federico ingegnere biomedico e un
ingegnere informatico e assieme
applichiamo al bando di finanziamento
regionale pin pugliesi innovativi
vinciamo il bando e fondiamo la nostra
start up
da qui in poi quella che era la mia
storia diventa la storia del nostro team
il bando finanzia le spese di avvio del
nostro progetto e ci permette di
costruire primi prototipi
nel frattempo il nostro team si allarga
si riuniscono a noi ingegneri meccanici
biomedici elettronici informatici
designer
e qui capiamo un'altra cosa importante
per lavorare insieme
c'è bisogno di collaborazione quando i
problemi sono piccoli una singola
persona può dare l'aiuto quando però i
problemi diventano grandi e necessario
collaborare
dobbiamo trovare persone che hanno la
nostra stessa dedizione e competenze
complementari da mettere a frutto
assieme collaborando dedizione
conoscenza e collaborazione sono queste
per me le fonti fondamentali che ci
possono aiutare a aiutare qualcuno
quindi andiamo avanti dopo il proto di
balsa sviluppiamo il prototipo beta
iniziamo a raccogliere fondi per il
nostro progetto
svolgiamo una campagna di equity però
funding durante la quale più di 100 soci
investitori decidono di crede nel nostro
progetto e vinciamo vari premi regionali
nazionali e comunitari ma piano piano
inizia a svilupparsi una coscienza una
presa di coscienza sempre maggiore noi
il nostro mondo non è costruito per
tutti il nostro mondo è basato sulle
esigenze della maggior parte della
popolazione quella che definiamo
normodotata non è costruito per chi
presenta una disabilità che
continuamente costretto ad adattarsi ad
un ambiente che non è stato costruito
seguendo le sue necessità
poche e poco adeguate se presenti sono
le tecnologie che permettono a persone
con disabilità visive uditive motori o
di qualsiasi altro tipo di
interfacciarsi in modo immediato ed
efficace con la realtà e con gli altri
individui sono questi invisibili di cui
parla oggi oltre il 15 per cento della
popolazione mondiale più di un miliardo
di individui vive con qualche forma di
disabilità
di questi circa 200 milioni incontrano
serie difficoltà nella vita di ogni
giorno
ma come possiamo fare qualcosa come
possiamo tendere una mano a questi
invisibili per me il primo passo è
quello di cambiare completamente il
nostro punto di vista sulla disabilità
mi spiego meglio con un esempio
immaginiamo di avere di incontrare un
uomo in carrozzina già al 100 metri
distanza probabilmente ci renderemo
conto della sua condizione
ma se questo momento stazione suo
scheletro
probabilmente dovremmo arrivare a 30 40
metri distanza per accorgerci andiamo
oltre
immaginiamo che fra 20 30 anni
esisteranno esoscheletri così avanzati
da poter essere indossati al di sotto
degli indumenti nessuno anche a pochi
metri di distanza riuscirebbe a
riconoscere la condizione di disabilità
di quell'individuo cosa voglio dire
capite bene che in questo senso la
disabilità non è più limite
insormontabile e assoluto dell'individuo
ma è un limite della società
dell'inadeguatezza delle tecnologie che
noi in quanto esseri umani abbiamo
sviluppato nel corso della storia
questo quindi spinge il nostro team ad
assuma una missione ambiziosa ma molto
motivante quella di costruire tecnologie
innovative per supportare concretamente
chi presenta una disabilità trasformando
questa disabilità in una nuova
possibilità di interagire con l'ambiente
e con gli altri individui concludo con
un aneddoto conoscete questa signora si
tratta di margaret mead e un'antropologa
statunitense del novecento che dedicò la
maggior parte della sua vita allo studio
delle culture primitive
vi racconto questo breve aneddoto che la
vede come protagonista non è verificato
ma secondo me è davvero molto
significativo
durante una delle sue lezioni uno
studente le chiese quale pensava fosse
il primo segno di civilizzazione in una
cultura
gli studenti si aspettavano risposte
come gli strumenti per la caccia i primi
strumenti religiosi all agricoltura la
med però li sorprese tutti affermando
che il primo segno di civilizzazione
fosse un femore fratturato e poi guarito
risalente a 15 mila anni fa guarigione
di questo tipo erano impossibili da
trovare in società primitive e selvagge
in cui invece abbondavano i segni di
violenza templi ricoperti di freccia
teschi spaccati da mazza e così via
queste società invece che guarivano i
propri appartenenti
indicavano che qualcuno si era preso
cura di quel ferito che l'aveva
accompagnato che aveva cacciato al suo
posto che si apre la sua cura di tutti i
suoi bisogni ha proprio personale
sacrificio durante il processo di
guarigione cosa impossibile che
avvenisse in culture selvaggio
la civiltà inizia quando iniziamo ad
aiutare gli altri
disse la mite vi saluto quindi con la
domanda iniziale da quale parte siete
oggi grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]